yeah are you good I think I'm good let
me get comfortable let me get her this
crap here cool I think this is pushing
that a little too much I got a little
sensitive head yeah your sensitive guy
know a lot of ways I am so finally after
five years of doing the podcast I'm
finally getting the opportunity to sit
down and talk to you from the moment I
started this podcast you were you know
number one top of the list guy that I
wanted to get with and and I just taken
this long to make it happen but I'm
super stoked to be sitting here to
unpack your story right me too me too
here we are I know it's amazing we had a
great swim this morning to get my butt
up and down the pool show me what's what
I felt good uh you were doing awesome
considering it listen you've been even
traveling a lot you haven't been so much
it was it was funded like you it was fun
to get in the water and just shake it up
a little bit yeah it was fun it was cool
yeah so I should say at the outset that
just to kind of create a little bit of
context when I began my plant-based
journey I stumbled across your Facebook
page this must have been 2000 sometime
in 2006 when did engine to come out
engine to officially came out in
February 25th 2009 2009 ok so when I so
maybe it was a little bit later maybe
2007 but I know that you were like
working on it yeah yeah at the time and
it hadn't come out yeah and we didn't
really know each other but I knew your
name from swimming and we had been at
the same meets growing up as kids you
went to Mercersburg where my sister swam
you know and I had followed your career
at Texas and we had had dual meets
against each other and the like and I
just remember I very vividly recall
looking at your Facebook that it's not
at some point I must have sought you out
to be a friend and you accepted it even
we didn't I was like you know following
old swimmers or whatever and I can't
remember exactly what you were posting
about but it had to do with the book and
kind of this movement that you're in and
what
we're working on and it was right at the
time when I was stepping into this and I
was like wow this guy he swam and he's
doing this and I think out of the blue I
sent you a message on Facebook and you
responded and we started a little bit of
a dialogue at that point and here we are
yeah so crazy to sit back and look at
what you've built and the number of
lives that you have impacted with your
work and your books and your advocacy
and what your family as a collective
unit has been able to accomplish is
really nothing short of extraordinary
mm-hmm well thanks a lot rich I mean
yeah it's been an amazing it's been an
amazing journey it's been an amazing
path and you know I think we vote we've
both been on our own amazing journey
being being advocates for plant-based
nutrition and yeah I mean you know my my
journey started in nineteen really 1987
is when I kind of plunged into this and
in large part because of my I shouldn't
say in large part but really because of
my father's research at the Cleveland
Clinic right so explain that a little
bit yeah people that don't know yeah so
uh for any listener that doesn't know
who my father is he he wrote a book
called prevent reverse heart disease and
really it's based upon his work at the
Cleveland Clinic going back to 1984 and
he got really just sick and tired of
surgery as a means of trying to address
a lot of breast cancer and so he was
like you know what in my lifetime it
will be probably pretty hard to show
that we can prevent reverse breast
cancer biting this way but I know that
you you can do it I'm betting that you
can do it with heart disease and so by
eating the save your heart you're also
saving your breasts and your prostate
and you know all these other things or
what gave him that idea to begin with
like when did he begin his own journey
with this way of yeah living yeah well
you know what so I think he started
looking at a lot of the epidemiological
studies that were out there he
saw this research that had been done on
green monkeys where they were able to
reverse the heart disease in green
monkeys so they basically fed them food
that gave him these a thirst erotic
plaques and then they would give them a
primarily a whole food plant-based diet
and then they were able to reverse it so
I was like wow if it can be done in
green monkeys and we have cultures on
the planet that for the most part having
no heart disease very little cancer
obesity I bet you we can do it so he
took he asked the cardiology department
the Cleveland Clinic to send him the
bottom of the barrel patients that have
been turned down for another bypass or
an angioplasty stand all those things
and over the course of like a year and a
half he got 22 patients and five years
later they're still alive ten years
later they're still alive 15 years later
they're still alive 20 years later
they're still alive and these are
remembered these are the walking dead
right and now all of a sudden there's a
walk you know there's a walking alive
they're like they're they're having very
amazing fruitful lives again and this
was back in the late 70s so this is
known this this all started in 1984 Oh
84 1984 at the Cleveland Clinic and so I
got to see what he was doing from 1984
to 1988 in 1987 I graduated from UT in
December of 1986 and that's when I was
off the athletic training table fare of
steaks and burgers and chicken and
pizzas and all that you know crazy stuff
and I immediately started eating this
way and you know and one of my heroes in
the sport of triathlon Dave Scott
six-time winner of the Hawaii Ironman
triathlon had been following this
particular way of eating and so I was to
me it was like a slam dunk I mean I'm in
I'm sold
health performance I don't I don't need
anymore anymore you know data or
convincing I'm sold and when your dad
began doing this correct me if I'm wrong
but I think I read somewhere that this
wasn't exactly a popular protocol at the
Cleveland Clinic the
because they make their money on surgery
right and suddenly he's helping all
these people and they don't have to go
under the knife anymore right no that's
you bring up a very very good point
there so 60% roughly 60% of the
Cleveland Clinic's revenue comes from
the cardiology department right from
doing all these you know you know
surgery stents angioplasty zits crazy
and so he he was not looked upon very
favorably at the cleveland clinic but
you know luckily he he he's pretty
self-confident when he's found the truth
and he's gonna like you know have that
be as his guiding light and he didn't
care how many people were calling him
doctor sprouts in the mail he would get
envelopes that had you know tree bark in
it and there was no return address I
mean it's crazy what people were doing
but he held he held fast to his guns he
knew he was you know barking up the
right tree and you know lo and behold I
think it was within three four years he
had proof of concept that yes this is
disease is reversible and then he's been
doing this now this is the longest
running study of its kind I mean it's
still ongoing and it's now you know
thirty five years later and he's been
written up and you know probably close
to eight or nine different medical
journey journals his latest that came
out in 2014 was the American was in the
American Journal of I think it was
Family Practice where he went back and
he looked at 200 patients that he had
that he had counseled to find out what
the compliance was compliance rate was
like four years later guess what it
guess what guess what it was I don't
know four years high right who is 90
percent wow that's amazing ninety
percent ninety percent of people still
mean still or maintaining that program
like hitting it out of the park and of
the remaining ten percent that didn't
file the program what's interesting is
67 percent of those ten percent 20
roughly 22 23 people that either passed
away had another heart attack
stroke surgery and of the 167 that
stayed with the protocol one male had a
small stroke so pretty pretty incredible
yeah I mean that high rate does not
surprise me you know I've met so many of
these people by participating in you
know some of your events and I've met a
lot of these people who have literally
literally been brought back from the
brink and they're so evangelical because
their health has turned around so
dramatically and unexpectedly
and they're just all about it like
there's no way they're going back yeah I
mean some of these people were so bad
off imagine that you're in a wheelchair
you're you're getting cardiac cardiac
disability because you can't go to work
because you're so far gone that you're
now in a wheelchair because your angina
so bad that you can't even stand up some
of these some of these these men there
and China was so bad just to shave in
the morning just this motion right here
right was so severe that they had to put
basically nitric and nitric oxide paste
nitro gluten nitroglycerin paste on
there on there right around here right
just so they could shave in the morning
well I mean I don't think anybody
realizes how far gone and out bad off
these patients we're half of them almost
half of them we're given what's called a
diagnosis of end-stage heart disease
which means you have less than a year to
live
Wow you know and the doctors order
marching orders were go home and get all
your affairs in order
and it's one thing to talk about
prevention and it's another thing
entirely to talk about reversal but when
you see the before and after angiograms
in your dad's book it's it's shocking
you know to see that reversal of what
happens when you go on this protocol and
you can actually open up those arteries
again and the plaque clears up and
suddenly the blood is flowing in a way
that it hasn't in many years yeah slow
unbelievable profusing the heart and
that's why you know people like ninety
percent how could he have that kind of
compliance like imagine if your life has
been basically whittled down to the
point to where you're in a wheelchair
you have no life whatsoever you can't
even walk without you know pain
discomfort and now you're also have your
reptile dysfunction and now a year six
months into the program you're like you
have no more chest pain you're walking
you're playing tennis you're dancing
with your wife you're having sex with
your wife you're gonna be intimate again
I mean wow I mean you can't put a price
tag on that stare it's unbelievable yeah
so he's doing this back in 1984 it was a
very different time the receptivity he
certainly wasn't what it was you know
what it is today and it's got to be so
gratifying you know for him and for all
of you and your family to see kind of
culture catch up and embrace this you
know it's it's it's amazing because I I
know when he started this in 1984 it was
a completely different world as far as
like him embracing this and now 2017
you know we've got everywhere I turn now
I see a book about eating you know
plant-based you've got all these
documentaries that are out there he and
he's and he and Colin it's Colin cam
right you know in Forks Over knives you
know it's in their own right they now
have been elevated to the status of
almost you know celebrities and in the
in the plant-based world and in and
again to me it's a testament of these
two you know one clinician one kind of
scientist that stuck to their guns they
knew were that they were doing the right
thing and and they've both made such an
impact on people's health in this whole
movement so let's talk about the
specific the specifics of what the diet
actually is for those who might be new
to the show or you know less familiar
we're talking about plant-based but this
is a very specific version of
plant-based yeah so well for the engine
to engine to diet or you prevent reverse
well yeah so that's or even to
gradations yeah you know yeah and more
but you know we could start with engine
- yeah so engine - so for the people
that don't know you know engine -
basically it's called engine - because I
was able to get a bunch of firefighters
in Austin Texas to drop the
because you were a firefighter we're
gonna track your story it's okay yeah
yeah yeah you're a firefighter yeah all
right engine to burn Austin firefighter
engine to help save a fellow
firefighters basically destiny with a
heart attack by by eating plants strong
following the Institute program but you
had a contest right like you made it fun
for all of these guys that you were
working with oh yeah yeah no yeah I mean
we had a little bar bet sitting out on
the porch that hey guys let's you know
who we thought was the healthiest and we
decided you know what to follow through
on this bet we're gonna go down to the
lab and we're gonna get our cholesterol
check and see who's got the lowest
cholesterol and that was when one of my
firefighting brothers his cholesterol
came back at 344 at the age of 33 and
you know most most humans or most
Americans rather have a cholesterol
between 200 and 220 v jr was 344 's his
father had triple bypass at 50 his
grandfather died before the age of 50
his great-grandfather died before the
age of 51 and so he was he was just
following down right that the family
path there and so jr. was and the T and
the crew there they were like game to
jump on board and try this and so in
2003 we started eating a lot of fruits
vegetables whole grains beans limited
amounts and nuts and seeds you know no
no extracted oils you know so we're not
doing olive oil canola oil safflower any
of these oils and within 28 days Jr's
cholesterol came down 148 points so
unbelievable yeah 148 points dropped
dropped about 14 pounds increase in
energy you know all the things that
happened asked acid reflux and digestion
bowel movement function all that stuff
so and that caught the attention of the
media right so suddenly there's
newspaper articles being written about
this what's this guy doing at the fire
department like he's got these guys and
on this crazy diet
their cholesterol is dropping and people
start paying attention to what you're
doing yeah I mean people start paying
attention the crowning blow was the New
York Times did a did a front-page piece
in like 2006 and then that's when it was
like Katie bar the door I mean we got we
got inundated with with letters emails
phone calls postcards just from people
saying why you guys are an inspiration
you know keep it up and then that's when
when I got a lot of offers from literary
agents and publishing houses to write a
book and I decided at some point after
that probably was three months after
getting some a lot of these these phone
calls and letters that you know what
maybe I can't write a book because
forever I was like who am I to write
about I got no business writing a book
I'm a doctor I'm not a health coach I'm
not a nutritionist I'm not a dietician
I'm an X X you know professional
triathlete that's now a firefighter but
at some point I was like you know what
maybe there's somebody out there that
would benefit from hearing this from a
firefighter and I got a decent platform
and so you know what let's let's give
this the old you know college try so
yeah I spent two years writing the book
decided to call it engine 2 because
that's where the whole thing you know
originated from that was a genesis of it
and did a pilot study to show the
efficacy of eating this way was 62
guinea pigs and yeah so that and then
the book came out in February 2009 and
that's how it all started yeah that book
blew up that was it was New York Times
bestseller yeah yeah it was a New York
Times bestseller and I was fortunate
enough to be in a lot of the morning
shows and stuff like that and yeah and
then a couple months later you know John
Mackey read it and and became a fan and
he asked me if I would consider coming
on board with Whole Foods to be a
healthy eating advocate and partner and
I said you don't twist my rubber arm
right
yeah and here we are at the Whole Foods
headquarters right now and you just
showed me your office I mean I obviously
I know you have a product line with
Whole Foods the into line and I'm
familiar with some of those products but
I didn't realize that you have 50 SKUs
yeah close to 50 I think it's 47 exactly
right now we're coming out with seven
new SKUs here just in a probably a month
or two but yeah it's it's you know so in
for the listeners that don't know what a
skew is because I didn't know you know
when I got into this in this business
with what's a skew basically for example
I've got cereals
and I've got three different types of
cereals right got the rips big bowl
cereal I've got the banana walnut the
triple berry and the original that's got
raisins in it so each one of those is a
SKU each one of those is askew within
the cold cereal category right and so
we've got hot cereals we've got granolas
we've got hummuses we've got crisps
bread crackers
we've got soups pasta sauces pizza
crusts veggie broth we've got two
different types of soup we got a we got
a firehouse chili we have a Moroccan
stew and and soon we're coming out with
some insane insane raviolis and some
amazing burritos it's great and they're
all no oil super low fat right and they
all follow the they all follow all the
criteria of engine 2 which is basically
got to be 100% plan strong right you
know I can find any animal products or
any animal by-products in there
everything's got to be low-fat so 25% of
the calories or less coming from fat and
it's got to be all naturally occurring
fat it's in the food right and then
everything's got to be low salt and and
what that means is if you look at the
number of calories per serving let's say
it's 220 like for the soup the ideally
the milligrams of sodium have to be
equal to that or less so for example
most soups that are out there you'll see
that there's 220 calories per serving
and the milligrams of sodium are like
almost three times the amount and by and
by following that one-to-one ratio or
less you're pretty much going to
guarantee that your daily sodium intake
is less than 2200 which is kind of the
upper limit according to the Institute
of Medicine right so we want to pay
attention to that especially considering
that you know what is it close to 1/4 of
the American adults are now in some sort
of hypertension medication I just read
an article this morning the he was in
CNN talking about how now we have more
obese Americans than ever before 40% 40%
of adults 19% of children it's insane
it's insane yeah it's insane you know
heart disease number number one killer
one out is still one out of every three
Americans will die one out of every two
will contract some form of heart disease
diabetes 50% of Americans by 2030
they're predicting will be diabetic or
pre-diabetic yep you know I say it all
the time these are these are the
epidemics of our era and when you really
like sit and ponder those statistics
it's insane
well what's the most insane thing about
it to me is it I think you know and I
know that we could abolish all this
literally in a matter of a year and a
half two years if everybody kind of had
this knowledge knew the power of a whole
food plant-based diet to not only to
prevent but also to reverse these these
diseases but instead you know were were
we're looking for procedures we're
looking for diets that don't work we're
looking we're barking up the wrong tree
everywhere we go and it's just making it
worse people are more confused than ever
and it's it's an absolute crying shame
yeah well on the confusion piece it's a
weird time because we've never had more
immediate access to information than
ever
yeah and part of that is amazing and
another part of that is you know creates
that confusion especially in the health
and nutrition space where there's so
much conflicting information and a lot
of time to read all this stuff and
they're gonna look at the headline
they're going to move on
nobody's reading these studies nobody's
taking the time to see how the studies
were performed or who made for them
right and they're just trying to get
through the day right and so how do you
cut through that morass and get the
truth out yeah it's not as easy as it
sounds
no no or they're gonna look at the
headlines maybe skim it and then just
look for some takeaways that allow them
right to have their butter to have feel
good about their bacon or whatever it is
I mean the latest cousin to the Paleo
that's just tearing it up right now is
the ketogenic yes I don't tell me I'm
interested in your perspective on that
because that is on center stage right
now oh it is it is well I mean basically
what they're saying is you can have your
bacon you can have your eggs you can
have your sausage you can have your
butter and as long as you kind of get
your body to go in this this state where
you're you're burning fat you're you're
doing minimal to no you know
carbohydrates you put your your body
basically into this starvation state you
can you can lose weight and you can
fight cancer and I think it's I mean
some of those dangerous things that's
out there and you know I had a I had a
woman at one of our immersions that we
just did in Sedona Arizona she hadn't
had a piece of fruit in a year because
her her personal trainer basically told
her that it's just gonna add pounds like
nobody's business so here's somebody
that's eatin bacon and eggs and butter
and cream cheese and all this stuff but
she's not even touching a fruit because
she's under the mistaken belief that
it's gonna go right to her thighs mmm
you know she's 90 pounds overweight and
you know it's crazy but the whole keto
thing it's amazing how the whole Atkins
thing just won't go away right as
MacDougall always says right you love to
hear you know good things about your bad
habits but you know it was Atkins and
then it was South Beach and then it was
you know paleo and now it's keto it's
like just you know just interesting how
how the focal point and the conversation
is pivoted like you don't hear so much
about paleo anymore it's all kind of
move towards keto and low carb
and and it's fascinating certainly at
the crux of that is the fact that people
want to hear good news about their bad
habits because that doesn't want to be
told that like they should be bacon for
breakfast is like I get it I think it's
something more than that to like I think
there's something about the way that
that that silo that that camp
communicates to the public and I think
they understand there may be a little
bit more internet savvy and fluent in
how we communicate in this modern age
and then perhaps our plant-based
community is I mean there's something to
be learned from that sure about how we
can improve because I feel like we're
challenged in really connecting with
people in a way that I think we're
capable of and I don't know what the
answer to that is yeah but we have some
work to do I think yeah and like for
example just last week ABC Good Morning
America did a did a segment on the this
new Kido book that's out there and this
beautiful news anchor was saying how
yeah I've lost weight and you know I had
breast cancer and now I'm fighting my
breast cancer and look what I can eat I
can eat sausage and bacon and eggs and
they actually showed her putting butter
into her coffee and I can tell you right
now in the air that we're living in now
that thing has gotten basically you know
forwarded on to that little five-minute
segment to more people that book was
number one on Amazon I mean it's just
like mm-hmm it's crazy and all that
igf-1 and casein and animal protein like
what's gonna happen carnitine and
lecithin or cancer and insidiously
destructive animal protein and
cholesterol and trans fats and saturated
fats it's just the list goes on and on
and on so what happens when someone
comes up to you and says yeah but like
saturated fat is not I like I read this
like that's been debunked like saturated
fat does not lead to elevated serum
cholesterol it's not that bad for you
we've been duped that was you know that
was propaganda by
the sugar industry or whatever you know
whatever vested interest like what is
your response to that because I'm sure
you've well the filled out all the time
well I would actually disagree I'd say
if you look at it for the preponderance
of the scientific literature when it
comes to saturated fat you'll actually
see that it actually does promote heart
disease that it it promotes type-2
diabetic insulin resistance that it
actually does fuel cancers but you know
really to me the bottom line is is that
you're not going to find saturated fat
in any plans I mean it doesn't exist in
plants yet in some nuts and some science
coconut coconut right right
but fruits vegetables whole grains beans
it doesn't exist so to me the saturated
fat it's the lifeblood it's really the
lifeblood of the the Paleo keto program
and so if you were to if we were to say
scientifically definitively saturated
fat is contributes to all these things
and it is a bad map of JAMA they
wouldn't have a program anymore so
they've gotta you know stand up and
scream and shout and say no there's
nothing wrong with saturated fat but
look at what it look they're better at
shouting you know because that ends up
on the cover of Time magazine or
what-have-you and what you just said
gets lost in the shuffle yeah yeah well
and in your and then look at look at the
look at the friends that saturated fat
keeps right at that whole laundry list
at you and I just rattled off there
right the igf right the quarantine the
less it then the wrong kind of
destructive animal protein the
cholesterol I mean it's just like that's
what you're also getting with saturated
fat right so let's just give them the
benefit out yeah there's nothing wrong
with saturated fat but everything else
that saturated fat lives with in the red
meat the chicken the fish the eggs the
you know the milk the cheese the butter
the the yogurt you can't get away from
it mmm all those things a sugar
it's about sugar rep well some people
believe it's about sugar I don't I don't
think it's a sugars not the culprit
know that people like to deflect a
little bit what about the idea that all
sugar is the same whether it's a fruit
or a coca-cola that's not yeah it's not
no because like the fruit so the I mean
the sugar that you're getting for
example in a banana or an apple or an
orange right it comes attached to the
fiber and that's the main difference
when it's attached to the fiber it can
act as a nice slow release of energy
over an extended period of time but when
it's just like pure you know white sugar
brown sugar and molasses or something
like that it leads to the the sugar
highs and then the lows and and then it
leads to increasing triglycerides and
potentially even you know elevating
cholesterol levels so but no eating
eating sugar fructose sucrose when it's
attached to fruit is like supremely
healthy and you know I mean you and I is
as athletes what's our by our body's
main source of fuel its its carbohydrate
it's not protein it's not bad as
carbohydrates and yet everyone is so
fixated on the protein thing right I've
been doing this ten years you've been
doing it much longer we swam together
this morning you kick my butt you were
the fastest guy in the pool you're 54
now almost 55 55 you're killing it so so
what about this you know let's just
clarify things for for people who are
listening this issue of protein and and
maybe even get a little bit more
detailed about this idea that okay well
you can get protein from plants but it's
not of the same caliber or quality as
the protein that you would get from an
animal source no you're right I would
say it's even better right it's a lot
better so when I'm talking to my kids 3
8 and 10 I let them know that you know
in this house we eat strong food so
we're eating foods that are strong
they're going to basically make you
bulletproof to chronic Western disease
they're going to give you an immune
system like a Canadian moose
so you basically very rarely if ever get
sick
and in this house were just not going to
eat weak foods and so that's why we're
not going to do red meat chicken fish or
eggs and I'd let them know that it's a
weak source of protein everybody thinks
it's funny because it's almost like a
180 from what we learned growing up so
traditionally we thought that you know
red meat and chicken and fish were
strong really healthy sources of protein
but the reality is is that there really
insidiously destructive they have a
proportion and composition of the
essential amino acids really 8 or 9
depending upon what you think that that
actually wreak havoc on our systems are
very pearl inflammatory in nature they
actually raise cholesterol levels you
know we talked a little bit early about
igf-1 animal protein especially those
the animal protein in dairy products can
actually turn on cancer cancer cells
initiate and propagate cancer cells and
and then you know if you're a female it
also contributes to leaching calcium
from the bones because it creates a
state of metabolic acidosis so I tell my
kids like listen so the strongest
form of protein that you're going to get
comes from whether it comes from fruits
vegetables whole grains or beans
that it's very friendly in nature it's
not gonna promote inflammation it's not
gonna leach calcium for your bones it's
not gonna bash your like your kidneys or
your liver you talked to somebody that's
having a you know kidney issues your
doctor will have you go on a low protein
diet because that animal protein bashes
the living out of your body or out
of your kidneys so you know and one of
the things that I don't think people
understand is that all protein all the
essential amino acids that are the
building blocks for protein originated
in plants that's where all originates
that's where like the true nutritional
engine for all and anything that's
beneficial and good in nutrition lives
in plants that's where it all originates
from so your proteins right if an animal
has protein and either direct
indirectly got it from plants right if
it's got vitamins either directly or
indirectly got it from plants
it's got minerals same thing right
that's where it all starts one of the
things that you hear consistently from
athletes on a plant-based diet or
athletes that that transition to a
plant-based diet is that suddenly their
recovery is enhanced right you kind of
touched on it a minute ago
and I think it has to do and I'm
interested in your thoughts on this it
has to do with your eating much more
anti-inflammatory foods right so you're
not eating all these inflammation
provoking foods you're getting your
protein but you're doing it in anti
inflammatory way and that allows the
body to recover more rapidly more
quickly you bounce back more quickly
you're less likely to get sick you can
go harder you go faster you can go
longer
otally you know it's like it's like you
know nature's EPO mm-hmm then protract
that out over a course of a season or a
number of years and that translate into
you becoming a better athlete yeah it's
not that eating plants makes you a
better athlete but it sets you up to
pursue a better trajectory for success
that's no brilliant you just said it
beautifully and the other thing you know
I don't think people realize I mean the
cleanest burning fuel out there you're
gonna get is from plants and it's an
athlete one of the things that is
crucially important for us as far as
their athletic performance is being
hydrated right I mean you you get a
little dehydrate your performance can
drop you know five percent just like
immediately and it takes eight times
more water to digest meat then it does
plant-based products and plus look at
look at all the inherent water that's in
plants I mean fruits and veggies are
roughly what 7080 percent percent water
in addition to that just the energy it
takes to break down all those foods
versus plant foods like your you have to
exert yourself that's why you get these
food comas and these lulls and energy
because your body has to metabolize all
these foods and they're difficult to
break down yeah yeah totally
no I mean yeah as far as recovery as far
as stamina as far as you know reaching
reaching your ideal weight I mean you
look you look across
you know all the pro sports that are out
there these days basketball football
baseball it's amazing to me how many of
these athletes are overweight right
they're overweight here they are this is
their profession right this is what
they're getting paid typically want
wonderful wonderful money to do and they
can't get it right when it comes to
their their diet and what to eat have
you worked with professional athletes
directly I mean there's a lot of them I
mean every day my Twitter feed somebody
sends me how so and so is gone you know
plant-based this person in that but it's
like it's interesting you know it's an
interesting moment in time where a lot
of these athletes are testing it out and
giving it a try no it's fascinating
I personally am not working with anyone
I mean I did get I know people reach out
to you behind the see yeah talk to
people well for like yeah I did yes for
example not too long ago the the GM for
the Atlanta Falcons right we've had
several phone calls back and forth about
me pop you know going in there and
talking to the guys Tony
wide receiver Gonzalez Tony Gonzalez
yeah yeah yeah he got kind of exposed to
it with Tony Gonzalez back you know
several years ago but and for those of
you they don't know Tony Tony Gonzalez
is the all-time reception has more
receptions of any tight end and I think
it was like with three years to go in
his career he read the China Study and
started going going plant-based but yeah
everyone you know Griff Whelan right a
wide receiver reached out to me a little
bit but yeah here and there that's cool
so during your swimming career though
you were just eating the Averett
whatever you like at the training table
at UT was pitiful yeah it was absolutely
beautiful but you know what it's kind of
one of those things when you're 18 19 20
21 you can almost get away with anything
yeah you know I mean just you're burning
so hot and when you're swimming four or
five hours there's nothing like swimming
to create an appetite huh it's crazy
it's nothing like like running cycling
forget it listening yeah but let's clear
something up because just that you can't
it doesn't matter how hot the engine
burns you're you know you're not gonna
you're not
gonna burn off you're right those those
athletic plot plaques the cholesterol
the fatty lesions you know whatever
whatever you're doing to start you know
some sort of cascade of cancer cells
that you can't you can't do that starts
early yeah I mean I think we we tend to
believe like I'm young I'll deal with
this later but you really start you know
heart disease starts when you're very
young as soon as you start eating those
foods that's when it begins yep no we
there's there's a there's we know from
studies right poor you know poor kids
who have died and you know automobile
accidents or whatever usually starts
three four five six years of age that's
crazy so after your swimming Kurt so you
swam at University of Texas you were I
mean you were all-american in Scituate
finalists on her back no you no you no
no I was I was an all-american but it
was on relays so I was I was on I was
400 freestyle relay yeah three three
years three different years and we were
we were top three three years but in an
individual you answer to ace wouldn't
know it's kind of painful no no the sort
of four years that I was there we got
two seconds into thirds yeah yeah I
think one of those years we lost to
Stanford might be true one was Florida
one was going to work Cal Berkeley when
beyond he was there yeah and all of them
are painful you look back and you're
like oh my god you know what happened if
this wouldn't have happened you know we
would have won by you know four points
you know right it's just it's just crazy
and after after so after the conclusion
of that you decide you're gonna dip your
toe in the end up becoming a triathlete
you become a pro triathlete yeah and you
were you had some good success and
that's right around the time when you
switch your diet that's right when I
switch my diet right yeah 1987 1987 is
when I started you know what would be a
ten-year career as a full-time
triathlete and yeah it was I mean it was
looking back it was it was quite a time
you know I was just really I was
training I was sleeping I was eating
healthily
I was looking for sponsorships Fleiss
man Oh nomadic backpack kind of a way of
living it was yeah no it was it was I
was at the right age to do it right my
early 20s but looking back I'm like god
I can't believe yeah you know what I
what I put up with what I went through
you know sleeping on couches lugging my
bike carrying case everywhere there
what's Papa easy thinking at this time
well that's interesting
so I mean gold medal I want the gold
medalist in rowing right right so tough
act to follow
well in a pasta and it possible iPhone
right so but so for the first I would
say five years my father was my biggest
fan biggest fan like you know would fly
all over the the world basically you
know watch me compete it was incredible
and then at some point I felt like well
I shouldn't say I felt he felt like it
was time for me to move on right move on
with my life
get a real job you know grow up and and
kind of stop this child's play and you
know he wrote me this really from his
heart just in looking back now that I
have kids just very loving the letter
that I already basically thought that I
was chasing after something that was
impossible for me to attain and it's
like a fools mistress and and that he
could not support me any longer
mmm not financially because he wasn't
but just could not support me
emotionally and all that stuff that's
that's a rough one
oh it was intense it was intense and so
from that point on around him I was a
closeted track triathlete right and I
still continue to do it
that you're doing it yeah yeah yeah but
I did it for another another almost five
years and then it was perfect because at
that in 1997 I was like I was almost 34
years old and it was it was a great
transition it was time I was like it was
time for me to get out I'd had enough
I'd had enough of that that's success
along the way were you first out of the
water in Kona
like yeah no listen I was you know over
the course of that ten years I became
the one of the premier swimmers in the
sport came out the water weather was
Alcatraz whether it was Kona you know
weather was all these you STS races
typically first if not first second and
Escape from Alcatraz I was out of the
water six years in a row first led the
bike would usually get passed on the run
by you know guys like Mike Pig Wes
Hopson Scott Tinley some of those guys
though I could throw down on a good day
I could throw down a 33 10k and some of
these guys you know 31 32 yeah so I had
some good success I mean I was
considered one of the top ten
Torino triathletes at the short court
distance the International distance 1.5
K swim 40k bike 10k run I was never a
dull traditions guy right I didn't do
the Iron Man's I did him twice just to
do it right I went to Kona and my first
year there 1994 I came out of water
first I led the bike for probably 40
miles you know I had two helicopters
overhead I had that I had I had you know
the motorcycles I had the cars I had you
know ABC Wide World of Sports I I wasn't
pacing myself I wasn't drinking I wasn't
fueling myself you know my longest my
longest I think ride run going into that
might have been you know an 80 mile ride
and a three-mile run for the most part
it is so funny because you know might
the first person to pass me was was Dave
Scott uh-huh and he passed me about
probably mile 40 right before you you
know climb make the climb of
yeah and he looked he looked amazing you
know in the back of his his his
hamstrings were just like a stallions
and I'm like there he is man there's my
man and any other of getting something
he got second that year to Greg Welch
uh-huh and he I think he threw down like
a 245 you know marathon there but
incredible but yeah I you know I just I
never really had the mentality to do
that the training that was necessary to
be good at the IRA to make the leap to
the longer this yeah yeah it's a whole
it's a whole different beast it's a
different sport it's a different sport
yeah two hours verse eight and a half
right nine yeah yeah so you do that you
get the letter you're underground for a
while alright yeah what's next yeah yeah
so I you know I continue doing my thing
I'm you know I'm living in I'm living in
Austin and that I absolutely know love
and adore and then at some point I was
like you know it's time for me to make
the transition and I'm like well what do
I want to do you know I know I don't
want to do a nine-to-five desk job and
you know what's my skill sets and and I
had some age group triathlon triathlete
buddies they were like you know what you
should like consider being a firefighter
it's like an amazing profession no two
shifts are ever the same you know it's
usually we go out and ten or fifteen
times a shift we're doing these amazing
deeds and helping people and saving
lives and so I went to fire station 1
which is the Animal House of the Austin
Fire Department and I went on a ride out
just to kind of see what it was about
and I was like oh this is this is like
amazing amazing you know getting on the
fire engine code three lights and sirens
you know go into an emergency your
Adrenaline's pumping your heart is
racing you know you're helping people
and you're doing it with a bunch you
know three or four other guys that you
become that become your brothers and
sisters so fast the camaraderie that you
experience from in a UT like reconnect
with that get to relive it
and but in a completely different
environment and so the you know that's
the thing I miss most about firefighting
because I've been gone now eight years
is that is that camaraderie you know
that that kind of fraternal bond that
happens I remember one time you said to
me it was on the cusp of you know you
really like breaking out with all the
things that you're doing now all these
opportunities and you're like it's great
it's amazing but you know I'm gonna have
to like walk away from being a
firefighter like you were torn up about
it like that's an embarrassment of
riches like that's a quality decision
problem to have right you know I just
remember the consternation like the
emotion that you had around that like
yeah that you were gonna have to let
that go in order to grow well it's funny
you say that because what happened is
you know John Mackey after I wrote the
book kind of you know pulled me into his
office and said hey you're right we're
you know white for you to consider being
a healthy eating partner and I said you
know let me think about it and I went
home and I talked to my wife Jill and
decided you know what this is really
probably a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity and and I was having dinner
at John's house and we walked out onto
the the porch and I told him you know
that I was just kind of wrestling with
this decision because it would mean me
having to retire from firefighting that
I've been doing now for for almost eight
years no I'm sorry twelve years and and
I remember saying you know ripp
sometimes in life you know you just
gotta you got to burn the ships to
really fully commit and yeah and so I
went home and decided you know what I'm
I'm gonna retire I'm gonna I'm gonna
retire from firefighting after 12 years
and I'm gonna commit to do this thing
with Whole Foods and yeah I mean it's
been you go back to the firehouse all
the time you know what I got I got I go
I go back to the fire I mean when I like
for example for UT football games mm-hmm
I'll go there and I'll use the parking
lot and go in and say hi to the guys
it's a whole new stable of guys now then
when I was there
and it's fun going to different fire
houses and visiting and stepping into
that environment again but probably six
to twelve times a year I go back and
visit I would imagine that I mean I
think people have this idea that
firefighting involves fighting fires all
the time but a lot of it is making these
house calls on people who are having
heart attacks that's right so it's is
that true like that's your you're
dealing with a lot of people that you're
kind of dealing with now in a different
way
yeah so it's sort of an extension of
that same kind of work is it is yeah so
I always tell people typically in my
talks that you know when I joined the
fire department I mistakenly thought
that the majority of our calls would be
these big old you know house fires and
we'd be going in and I'd be fighting the
dragon and or slaying the dragon
and you know rescuing you know kids and
grandmas you know out of the house and
that's not the case at all for the most
part eighty to ninety percent of our
call volume as firefighters across the
country are medical emergencies so we're
going in and we're helping somebody with
a diabetic emergency because their
fasting glucose or their glucose has
gotten too low somebody that's got
having difficulty breathing somebody
that's got chest pain somebody that's
had a heart attack and and they are
actually not breathing they they're
pulseless breathless and we have to you
know start pumping on their chest and
try and bring them back to life lifting
assistance calls where we're helping
people that are morbidly obese get out
to the ambulance typically eight or nine
of us putting them on some sort of a
well they they have this device now
called a mega mover right and mega mover
where you you know and it can hold up to
a thousand pounds Wow device we didn't
need twenty thirty years ago no no this
stretchers the stretchers themselves now
there are these hydraulic stretchers
that hold up to I think it's twelve
hundred pounds because so many
firefighters and EMS personnel were
throwing out their backs you know
getting these these these patients up
onto the
under the stretchers so yes we see you
get to go yeah it close and personally
the acute version of the preventative
side that you now focus that one see the
devastation is caused by the fork the
spoon the knife yeah that's amazing
so now one of the main things that you
do with Whole Foods is you spend half
the year traveling around doing these
immersion programs with the employees of
all these stores all over the country
right how many stores well that's not
quite right so so what it is so the
immersions versus just the offense right
so these the seven-day immersion program
we usually do two of those a year and
one of those is is is designated for
whole food team members right that are
that are really you know that are sick
and have to medically qualify to go the
other and so that's to one week out of
the year and then another week is for
the public but I'd say six to seven
months out of the year probably close to
a hundred to 120 days a year I'm on the
road I'm going to whole food stores I'm
doing customer facing events basically
shouting from the rooftops you know get
planned strong right you know stop stop
the red meat the chicken the fish the
eggs the dairy products and instead
start substituting all these healthy
plant-based foods plant strong foods and
then I'm also in the back of the house
with the team members I'm also giving
them a little like you know hey guys
this is one of our core values as a
company right is to promote healthy
eating to all Whole Foods shareholders
and you know I was brought on board in
2009 here's my story you know if any of
you are hurting if anybody in your lives
are hurting think about it and we also
have this product line that basically is
a whole food market exclusive brand and
this is what it stands for you know X Y
Z right low fat plant strong and and
then I show them a compare like you know
a can of the engine to pasta sauce verse
typical canna pasta sauce and the
difference in sugars and sodium and
cheeses and animal products and all that
stuff
so it's me educating right the and
there's now there's almost a hundred
thousand whole food team members across
the country that's amazing yeah so it's
it's it's a never-ending stream of
trying to educate people mmm it really
is
so yeah it's so what you know and I am
forever thankful because because of John
Mackey I now have this bully pulpit in
this platform to basically take the
message from my original book the
Institute diet book and and I'm sharing
it with people it seems like almost
every single day in my life nothing yeah
I could I could not imagine a more kind
of Purpose Driven fulfilling you know
life right so Papa E's all good that's
actually very brilliant yeah you know
what so things with my dad are fantastic
and it one of the beautiful things is
that my dad and I now you know you know
you've attended and you've been a guest
speaker at a lot of our events I asked
my dad and my mom and my sister to be
speakers at a lot of the engine to
events I should say all the engine to
avenge the immersion programs our
weekend events plant stock and so it's
like it's really it's a family affair
now it really is yeah it really is and
you know for the listener every year you
do this event called plant stock it's at
your family farm and this is this farm
is insane it dates back generations in
generation 1675 this is the largest
single family owned farm in the eastern
seaboard or something like that at some
point close close its what it's one of
two family farms in the state of New
York that have been owned and operated
by the same family for over 300 years
yes it's unbelievable it's beautiful and
you invite all these people to come and
you have this amazing speaker lineup but
the point I'm trying to make is that
this is a family affair and it's like
every single person in your family is
involved and participates and
contributes yeah not just to this event
but to this message like and and to see
that cohesion it's really it's really a
powerful thing unbelievable like I can't
imagine when you are you know a 19 year
old swimmer but you thought you were
gonna be doing right but it's really
beautiful
yeah thanks rich no it's
it is really beautiful and I know you
didn't come to this this year's planned
stock but it was they're all amazing and
wonderful and special past years was the
best it was it was really magical I mean
the weather was idyllic we we had two
two of the Jumbotron screens instead of
one because we had almost 600 people and
there wasn't one bad seat in the house
we arranged that big wide aisles didn't
matter where you were you know you
didn't have a bad bad seed
you know the meals the food was was off
the charts we had really good gender
parity and when it came to you know men
and women's speakers this year it was
almost half and half which was which is
really important for me this year and
nothing like nothing likes having two
and a half days we had a we did a big
Friday night event this year so we had
an ice cream social and my dad told the
story of winning his Olympic gold medal
oh wow
and we actually show a story and we
actually showed footage of it yeah
so if you ever get my dad on the podcast
yeah ask ask him to share that story
with you yeah but and then here you are
you know for to almost two and half days
and what do you have underneath your
feet grass amazing lush you so you're
firmly you're firmly planted on earth
right you know and yeah and everything
it's such a tight contained environment
there and one of the things that's
always made it special to me is that the
speakers for the most part they always
hang out they hang out and so everybody
these conferences you buzz in you do you
blow out you know you're not really
participating in the event
know we're all hanging out in your
kitchen staying up till 2:00 in the
morning talking or whatever yeah but the
participants also have access to you -
John - you know Eric Adams whoever it is
because they're there and they're
accessible and it's like wow you know
this this is really cool
interestingly enough we're not having
plant stock 2018 at the family farm yeah
yeah you know what we just decided it
was time to kind of shake things up a
little bit you know we've we've been
there six six years in a row now
and so for the seventh one we're moving
to this it's going to be just as magical
in a different way it's the Blue Ridge
assembly it's this it's this 1500 acre
campus in the Black Mountains of
Asheville North Carolina and everybody
can stay on site and you're there's
different levels if you want you know
deluxe accommodations economy or or
dormitory style and so you know plant
stock it was like 595 you know just to
come and you had to also do your kind of
B&B and drive and rental car and all
that you fly into Asheville take your
uber there and then you stay on site and
it's like you know you can do I can
economize all in that includes
everything right I mean yeah that's
clewd talks every session and room and
board I mean it's like crazy I think the
economy piece is really important and
when we talk about you know you should
go plant-based and we're talking about
Whole Foods
you know we it's easy to start getting
weld into this idea that this is a
lifestyle for the well-heeled only that
this is an affordable thing for most
people I can't afford to shop at Whole
Foods I can't afford to go to plant
stock no am I gonna be able to do this
so how do you how do you think about and
communicate around that issue well it's
funny you know I was I was uh I was in
Boston not too long ago and I had an
uber driver there was 300 plus pounds
was telling me how it's got young kids
she's got type 2 diabetes and how he you
know he wish he had the energy to play
with his kids and so I told him he said
what do you do and I said well I'm
actually I'm a healthy eating advocate
and I teach people you know how to
reverse her diabetes and how to get you
know how to find their ideal weight and
all these things and he's like oh tell
me how do I do it and I say well this is
what you want to do you want to avoid
animal products dairy you want to start
focusing in on plant strong foods and he
immediately yeah well one of his
objections he had many but was well you
know you can't I can't I got it hard I
he's like I can't afford to eat healthy
and I said well let me stop you right
there I go what you need to understand
is this is peasant food right as soon as
you understand this is peasant food
we're talking about rice and beans and
potatoes and bananas and you can do
frozen that is like just as nutritiously
sound you know buck ninety-nine a pound
never goes bad you just take what you
need out of the freezer and you're good
to go
but you kind of saying that it's too
expensive to eat healthy would be like
you saying well I can't I can't afford I
can't I can't drive because I can't
afford a Porsche all right I can't eat
healthy because you know yellow bell
peppers $4.99 a pound an organic you
know and so you know you take that out
of the equation
I say listen oatmeal how much is oatmeal
Oh peels like drop dead cheap sweet
potatoes you know pasta with a nice you
know little little marinara sauce on top
if I had to I could I could live on
probably about 11 11 bucks a day eating
this way easily easily and that's not
even buying or buying in bulk and I bet
I could probably make it for under 4
bucks a day if I really was trying yeah
the the conversation about wellness gets
conflated with superfoods and all these
sort of you know essential oil whatever
it is like all of these expensive you
know top of the pyramid items and the
truth is wellness is you know being
hydrated getting a good night's sleep
it's eating the foods that that fuel you
best and heal your body and it doesn't
have to be it's not exotic it's simple
no but as human beings we want to
overcomplicate it
we want to know okay you're telling me
that but take me beyond the velvet rope
where's the VIP make it harder than it
is yeah
and when you say it's it's right I mean
I could eat rice and beans with like hot
sauce like every day and there's plenty
of times I do that's exactly what I know
you know on a salad or whatever like I
I'm fine with that you know but a lot of
people want to make it harder and then
there's like this weird psychological
resistance to just accepting like it can
be this easy
ya know cannon beachy
and that's and that's why in the new
book that I wrote the seven-day rescue
diet it's all about building these like
really economical really quick bowls the
whole concept is about bowls the whole
recipe section and and when I was
writing the the recipe section with my
sister Jane and we were doing our pilot
studies we did want to mesquite texas
into a cleveland with 180 people we gave
them down to the like letter like okay
this is what you this is what you should
have for breakfast lunch and dinner we
gave them a company and grocery grocery
lists for everything and nobody was
filing it and it's because you know what
people they're they're super busy they
don't have time to go grocery shop and
they don't have time to make you know
make these meals and a lot of them were
pretty darn simple and so I said Jane we
just have to let's meet people where
they are and so we've now got four
different Bowl concepts and four for
breakfast lunch dinner and then kind of
salads and then you know you pick your
foundational ingredients that you like
you pick you know you're different like
legumes that you like your different
toppings that you like different sparks
that you like and then you're you're set
and so you do that for breakfast lunch
and dinner find you know a core
assortment of ingredients and now these
are no recipe
builder bowls there's no you have to
follow one single recipe right and
people are loving it that's great loving
it that's great yeah so in the hundreds
and thousands of people that you
encounter you know during your travels
and these events that you do you know I
would imagine you have a pretty good
sense like I'm interested in some of the
success stories but I'm also interested
in you know what you've learned about
the psychology and the you know kind of
emotional component that circulates
around healthy eating habits what works
what doesn't like what is it that is
tripping people up the most or creates
the most challenge for people trying to
you know live better and embrace this
way of living mm-hmm
well the biggest challenge is always
yourself right you're always your
biggest hurdle and once you can like get
past that yeah that's huge
but yeah if you've had a heart attack if
like if you're in pain and you're up
against the wall that choice is easier
but what if you're just you know what I
don't feel good I'm like I'm just I'm
heavy
I'm lethargic but you're not quite at
that pain point yeah yeah we so I just
you know I just did a immersion with
eighty eighty two people in Sedona
Arizona and most of these people are
there they're overweight they're sick
they're they're not doing well and
they've seen you know other forks over
knives or what the health or one of
these documentaries and I think they
realize that something about you know
this these documentaries or they've read
prevent reverse or one of my books are
like something about this resonates with
me but I got to just figure out how to
do it and and so that's what I mean
that's what we try and do at these
emergencies we try and basically show
people that not only the you know why
they want to do it but also how to do it
and but I'm just trying to figure out
because I want to I want to answer your
question but yeah but I think what I'm
really getting at is just you're meeting
all of these people there's a lot of
success stories but I'm sure you meet
people that like are sort of in that
cycle of like they do it for awhile they
fall off they do it you know they're
getting back it's kind of like that
human thing of like yeah how can we just
like how can you just get it to click in
with people and like what works what
doesn't I don't know that there's a
magic part of that no I mean if you talk
to Dan Buettner he'll say well you got
to make the Healthy Choice the
convenient choice right you know I can't
try to get them to shift their mindset
you just got to make sure it's within
their reach at all times that they're
out during the day yeah I get that
convenient and easy and accessible yeah
well that's all stuff that we you know
we we talk about as well it's like yeah
you got to get a you got to get rid of
all the barriers all the all the excuses
all
all the things that are going to wreak
havoc on you so we don't want this to be
about willpower right and so we got to
create an environment obviously in our
in our lives and our houses at work in
the car that it's not going to have you
like reaching for that pile of
pistachios or you know reaching for the
the cashews and I'd say one of them you
know the most important principles that
we teach people at these immersion
programs is calorie density and so
within the actual plant-based world what
foods is it that you can learn to eat
until you're comfortably full at
breakfast lunch and dinner and in the
disconnect a lot of times is people
people think that they can have a couple
spoonfuls of peanut butter that they can
have you know you know an avocado that
they can have a little bit of oil and
and these things add up in a hurry and
you do them repeatedly again and again
and again and if you're you know you
have a genetic predisposition to heart
disease you know forget about it you're
not going to extinguish those little hot
spots right it's going to continue on
you know and as my dad likes to say he
doesn't want his patients having one
thimbleful of anything that's going to
ignite their heart disease so he played
you know he plays hardball and with the
seven-day the new book the NGT seven-day
rescue program you know we're we're
playing hardball too and because this is
really for people that are trying to
rescue their health you know you've got
one of the the big four you know chronic
Western diseases and you're trying to
address it and we know we know that if
you follow this protocol you can not
only stop it but you can reverse it so
you got to create an environment in your
life that's conducive to it you ideally
you have people around you they're
supportive to it you know and if not you
got to figure out a way to enlist them
so that they're they're not going to
sabotage your best efforts with this
the whole human psychology got
ultimately you gotta want it you know
it's like you can't you can't will
somebody into wanting it for themselves
you can you know it's like you can lead
them to water but you can't make them
dredge it's amazing how you can drop an
alcoholic off in rehab but if he doesn't
want to quit drinking he ain't gonna
quit drinking yeah yeah and so it's
emits amazing how some people their
self-starters right they they get the
information and they get it it's no big
problem other people's other people that
you know they fight tooth and nail and
you know they're just they for whatever
reason they know that this is the way
the path to go down but they just for
whatever reason they have a hard time
making a stick you know I mean it's it's
probably goes back to the whole pleasure
trap right Doug Lyall and you know you
know we're looking you know for we want
to conserve energy we're looking for the
greatest amount of pleasure we're trying
to avoid pain and everything about the
environment we live in and now in 2017
is you know I mean look at where we sit
in our self driving cars practically now
and we go to the drive-thru
we're not exercising one iota all the
food is super super you know highly
processed no water no fiber a fraction
of the vitamins and minerals and it
lights up our our brains like a pinball
machine right and all that salt all that
sugar all that fat and so you're asking
people to walk away from that you were
asking people well we got to down
regulate all those receptors in our
brain to those things and now we have to
develop new cravings and new likes to
you know steamed kale broccoli with a
you know a little smidgen of
no-salt-added Bensons you know seasoning
to it a nice piece of you know marinated
a cauliflower steak a tofu steak whole
grain whole grain crust pizza with
sun-dried tomatoes and and spinach and
black beans and pineapples
I mean this this food can be so insanely
delicious that you know it's just crazy
and so that's I think that's you know
one of the things that for people that
don't know anything about this is that
ultimately you're not you don't to give
up anything you just have develop a
whole new set of you know kind of
tastebuds cravings and and then what
opens up before you is a whole new world
of health that you never dream was was
available to you one of the things that
I hear fairly regularly if you bring up
Forks Over knives or the China Study is
this knee-jerk reaction like oh that was
debunked oh stuff I read that that was
debunked and it's dismissed it's just
out of hand dismissed without and to
even further discuss it is to is to you
know be somebody who doesn't understand
what's going on
so do you hear that like to you how do
you respond to that you know what I
don't you don't know it with four years
out all the time with forks over knives
I don't and maybe it maybe it's because
you know my dad was one of the right the
the main threads going through it right
he and Colin you know I I had a little
cameo in it but I don't have I don't
have people come up to me saying yeah
I'll be saying it to you they're not
gonna say their face but there's sort of
this meme on the internet like oh that
was it probably began with Denis mangers
blog post which I don't know if you're
familiar with that or whatever which I
think she recanted I think she did
recant that one thing yeah yeah they
were canting didn't get as much
attention and no it didn't of course you
do
but that that's sort of a mindset that's
sort of percolating out there like oh
yeah like that no that wasn't true or
whatever yeah you know it's funny I I've
I don't I don't spend too much time like
with all the naysayers and all the
people that are trying to debunk
whatever it is I'm just I find I'm too
busy
I'm too busy I'm just plowing forward
you know doing my thing and I mean in my
heart of hearts it's like this is
like this is it I mean its whole food
plant-based it is or at least
plant-based it's it's the answer to so
many things that are like taking us down
right now right it checks every box if
you checked it exactly this it does and
and I guess it's just amazing to me that
that other people don't see it as as
clearly as we do maybe it's almost like
a Republican you know democratic thing
it's like well I don't know I don't know
that it's a it's it's not it's not a per
se democratic or no nothing but in the
way that our trains op that's what I'm a
how we just we silo ourselves yes um you
know idea of the world or world view
that becomes very difficult to uncheck
all us from yeah you know yeah whether
it's religion or politics I mean foods
right up there you know it really is
it's it's difficult not to crack but
with you being you know on the front
lines and I mean you're doing one-on-one
like you're face to face with these
people all the time and I can't imagine
well I can't imagine because I have
experienced it on some level but that
that that when you see these people and
you you know some time has gone by and
you see the change or they give you a
hug and they're crying and they're like
you know you changed my life like this
is they have a new lease on life as a
result of like this work that you're
doing there's there's nothing more
gratifying or more worthy and for me
when I get those emails or I meet those
people it's like I just want to shout it
from the mountaintops yeah you know it's
like I want everyone I want everyone to
experience what that person just
expressed to me yeah yeah no I am I
sometimes wish that I had somebody
filming right when I'm doing you know an
event or book signing whatever I can be
arranged yeah I know but but then the
person that's sharing it probably
wouldn't you know might feel a little
self-conscious yeah but but just saying
you know gosh you know you I just want
to thank you you know you you know you
and your father your family you know
save my life and then they tell me their
story and it's like yeah they're like oh
you must get sick of hearing this like
now
no never never get sick of hearing this
and then I let them know I said listen
you know I appreciate you thanking me
but you know what you did this you did
this you took this information you like
you owned it and now look where you are
and it's you know congratulations big
high five to you so we got to wrap this
up in a minute but I would love to be
able to leave people with you know some
takeaways if somebody's listening and
they're stuck maybe they've tried to go
plant base but they laughs or they're
interested they just don't know how to
begin like how do you suggest that
people embark on this journey well I
would start by reading some books
reading you know watching some
documentaries if you specifically want
to like learn more about engine to go to
engine to comm we have an amazing
amazing community and support group
there's a ton of resources on that I do
a lot and around the launch of the new
book the seven-day rescue we created a
private Facebook group and we've now got
over 22,000 members on there it's the
most supportive loving nourishing did a
little thing I did a little thing there
he sure did yeah I don't know last year
something did generating that engagement
was crazy people are so into it yeah
yeah it's it's it's a really beautiful
community but you know so as far as
somebody that wants to like get involved
with this I would say I would tell
somebody like jump into my new book the
seven day rescue because to me it's it's
I've taken you know the all the data
that I didn't have that is in this book
since I wrote you know engine - so since
2009 it's all these new studies all this
new data I mean it's just it's it's
incredible I basically break it down
into seven super simple pillars that I
ask you to follow for for seven days and
then you'd be the judge on day eight
what you want to do going forward and
then you know do it if you if you sign
up to do it you get an email from me
every day for seven days with an
encouraging you know
word of advice and then also a recipe a
simple buildable and then you know if
you go in and then join the the private
Facebook group you've got I mean so you
got the book
you got the emails you got the recipes
you got the community I mean and you
know community peace and the support is
huge
especially for people that are trying to
do this without that you know support
and their own home yep yeah that's
crucial yep yep huge so yeah and there's
then there's so much cool stuff that's
this coming down the pike you know not
only with me but with just you know this
movement you know yeah I know you know
about this flick coming out called the
game changers and you know 2018
I think that'll like move the needle in
a big wonderful amazing way much like
Forks Over knives yeah but but hopefully
this'll like really really speak to the
men that are out there yeah I think it's
gonna have a huge impact on people yeah
yeah it's exciting yeah yeah man it's
good man and when are you gonna when you
when are you gonna what's what's your
next athlete exchange you're gonna get
back in the pool come on man
yeah I know so we'll see about 2018 you
know I miss getting the world record for
fifty to fifty four year olds in the
200-meter backstroke bye-bye just a few
seconds and but if I would have done it
for 55 to 59 year olds I would have
gotten right the world record so I just
have to hang in there basically forever
there for it till January till January
and then you got to get it because when
that movie comes out you want to be able
to go yeah maybe maybe maybe I know I
know it's so funny how you know we I
know I I feel like I put I put so much
pressure on myself you know our fair
amount in life you know with everything
it's like if I really want to add this
like to the to the list of things like
yeah but I think it can energize you and
I think it gives you it gives you a
little structure and then it
it makes going to the pool easier
because there's a purpose to it you know
and it fundamentally it serves the
mission and the message that you're
trying to get oh yeah because those kind
of actions speak louder than words you
can get up and say whatever but like
when you demonstrate that athletically
and you're more than capable of doing
that it's powerful man and people pay
attention to that like I think it's
important and I think I think it's you
know it's a worthy it's a worthy thing
it's not it's not like a silly whatever
like I think you know and it's what you
do dude I saw I was in the pool you this
morning you're tearing it up you know
what people know what that's all about
yeah yeah but I also know the pain
that's he Alves and yeah you've known
that pain your whole life it's funny I
have known in my whole life but it's I
had been removed from it - I mean like
tearing it up in a workout is one thing
but like putting the gas to the to the
to the metal for a race that's almost 2
2 minutes and 20 seconds where you know
halfway through you feel like you're
breathing out of your eyeballs and you
know your legs are stuck in cement it's
like wow I'm 55 and I'm and I still
really want to like do this and yeah I
guess maybe I do but the pain the pain
it was a lot worse than I remember it
when I was in my 20s in too few minutes
of pain for this for the plant-strong
you know I know I know I do I think I
need I need to give you a call maybe
once a week and have you pump me up I'm
happy to do it if I lived here I'd be at
the pool with you every morning so yeah
it's fun awesome
well great talking to you as I ate it at
the outside of the show you know you've
been a not only like a personal
inspiration to me even an amazing mentor
to me and thank you for all the guidance
that you have thanklessly given me over
the years my life is indelibly impacted
by your example and your work and your
friendship and I really appreciate it
and again it's like the service that
you're doing to the world and that your
family is
actively engaged in is really quite
remarkable and I just wish you only win
in your sales and great success with
trying to impact as many people as
possible on this this mission that we
share awesome and before we go let me
just say too that when I first met you
at the vegan world that's right health
is like some tiny little thing in LA
yeah it was in LA which it was it was
billed as something huge right that you
flew out it wasn't all that a little
table but but no but and I met you and I
met Julie there and you had just gotten
into this bike accident in your lip
remember your lip and but we ought you
up on stage and we had a little calf off
or she who had the biggest calves and I
remember talking to you and I remember
like saying you know what you got a book
in you dude you got a book in you and
then you were the first person to to
sort of give me that confidence and I
remember you introduced me to your pokie
agent and I had a called I just wasn't
ready like I had no I didn't know what
to say to the guy and he was like yeah I
don't you know like rightfully he was
like yes I don't think this guy's ready
to write a book which was a good lesson
for me like I needed to spend time and
really think about what I wanted to
write but when I finally did you were
the first person that I sent you know
the manuscript to and you like called me
back like within days and and you know
what you said to me I'll never forget
well I I read that thing in a matter of
hours and I was like oh my god this
thing is like I loved how you just but
you bared at all
and I didn't know I didn't know all that
about you know about your personal story
and your personal journey and I was like
this is crazy man this is beautiful it
was a beautiful beautiful book and look
I mean and so right back at you man like
look what you have done since since I
met you then right and I wasn't I think
it was 2009 that's right yeah I think it
was summer of 2009 yeah and you know you
yeah it's so beautiful to me to see what
you have done in this movement with your
podcast with you and Julie you know with
your with your with your events your
books and that's one of those things
where we can both look at each other and
say hey you know we knew each other when
cool and yet millions of people are
suffering out there man and there's a
lot of work to be done and that's that's
what it's about and we're yeah yep I
mean that'll be interesting to see where
we are in a decade well come back and
spend five years since I've been chasing
you maybe we could do it yeah yeah
anyway awesome man if you wanna if you
want to connect with rip engine to is
men shoot die kamar engine to calm and
shortened oh just engine to engine to in
to to that engine to on all the social
networks and all that kind of stuff yeah
and check out one of his he check out
plants talk man plant stack 2018 we
already have 200 people signed how are
you
so we're good at you we're gonna cap it
it probably 700 uh-huh I said get on
that people yeah
all right now thanks brother thanks
peace engine to plants
cool man I ran out I ran out I ran over
your ending there yeah now it's good I
like to I can mix it up